[Music]
PETA you are eliminated Nick violin his
Dancing with the Stars partner Peta
Murgatroyd were sent home after Monday's
double elimination et's Cameron Mathison
was backstage at the show along with
special correspondent and former Dancing
champ bindi Irwin what are you going to
take away from this experience it's just
fun to get out your comfort zone and
challenge yourself and you know
certainly I got nervous a ton of times
when I did that but just just to have
fun any time you like take a risk and go
for it and you know that's kind of been
the biggest takeaway for me and that's
what I'll always remember about it who
do you get your advice from it's a
collection of people PETA the most for
sure she's my partner and Max and
Vanessa honestly vanessa is always a
calming you know she's always supportive
max always gives me a pep talk for the
dances so yeah we definitely keep it in
the family
will we continue to see you on
television in any capacity well you got
I know you got offers coming in I have
no plans right now right now I'm focused
on launching my business next week May
8th the polish gent really excited about
that and that's gonna take a lot of my
times and obviously with Vanessa and
that's what I'm focused on right now
if Peter you got a little bit more mom
time I do yes tomorrow morning I don't
have to be anywhere so stay at home
change diapers how do you look this hot
after having a little I mean seriously
want to make up an eye
honestly
[Music]
you